one of the biggest targets for your iron
and or at least your your amusement or
befuddlement is is Max tegmark and and
those people of of his his kind that
that like to promulgate the idea of what
he calls the mathematical Universe uh
which is not only one Multiverse as I
understand it it's at least four
different kinds of multiverses some of
which I don't think are controversial in
other words that he says there are
things we cannot see that are outside of
our Horizon I don't think you would
disagree with that you might say that
that's not a Multiverse but but at any
rate
um why why do you say as you do in the
book uh you know that that this you know
kind of thing was probably done to sell
books and and for that it was quite
successful why does that particular
um uh conjecture uh annoy you as you say
I don't think I say this in the book I